scientists recently discovered the  interesting cut brain connection in  parkinson's disease this disease is  characterized by death of the  dopaminergic neuron in substantia [ __ ]  and the lewy bodies recently scientists  figured out a connection with gut  microbiome and saw that the gut  microbiome is severely altered in  parkinson patient compared to a healthy  individual taking the gut microbiome  when they inject it into a mouse  they found out that mouse displays  several symptoms of parkinson's disease  like motor defects and inflammation  moreover  when scientists inject the  aggregated form of alpha-synuclein which  is responsible for parkinson's disease  formation  that can transfer from gut  through the vegas nerve and it can  ultimately spread into the brain this  brings out the gut brain connection in  parkinson's disease  and this is an interesting insight to  the parkinson's disease development  that's one minute see you in next